welcome back to the game sweat stage
here III 2015 i am joined by justin i'm
kyle from popcap bringing us plants vs
zombies garden warfare 2 so guys we just
poke a little bit about this before we
started rolling but the reveal on the
Xbox stage in what has been one of the
best series ever how does that feel it's
honestly amazing I mean it was it was
great to be able to show our game on
both stages I think it's a testament to
sort of where garden warfare has you
know grown too I mean when we started
garden warfare one it was a small game
in fact it was just going to be an xbox
live arcade game and you know
PlayStation Store game and halfway
through development we were like wow you
know this this is really something like
this is really fun and so we like we we
should add more so then you know it's
just going to be competitive multiplayer
then we added our co-op mode we just
kept adding features and features and
then that was garden warfare one you
know fast forward to today and we have
garden warfare 2 and as you can see
we're really throwing pretty much
everything we have at this game so I
mean it was it was a bit surprised isaac
funds a punch once at zombies because
you're taking a tower defense game and
you're putting your taking a shooting
game and putting tower defense in it
you're taking tower defense of putting
shooting in it but it works and it's
your kind of in that amazing company
where it's a shooter but it's not
something that's bloody and gory and
it's fun absolutely you know the plants
vs zombies franchise is built off its
characters great characters and then
this world is kind of evolving around it
and that's where the ton of fun is for
us so basically we've started off with
these characters and started bringing
them to life and they've evolved over
time into where and the sort of a core
pillars that we develop them you know
the game is based off of accessibility
humor and depth and you just those when
you put those pieces together something
like garden warfare comes out where you
you've got fans of us shooters fans that
really like the death of a shooter
mechanic but when you add in the
accessibility pieces the humor it
appeals to a really broad audience and
it's your not their twitch oh my gosh I
died it's okay when you get killed by a
dancing sunflower it's kind of funny you
laugh at it and yeah you're back out
into the garden doing your next sort of
thing
see is that all the characters I mean we
can see here they like the funny to
watch they have their own personalities
they're just adorable and even even
zomboss himself is like he's an adorable
village yeah yeah we spend a lot of time
on our character development we go
through multiple iterations every single
one we want to find that charm that
humor I mean humor is so important for
this game we want it to be a a
competitive strategic and deep game but
we also wanted to make people laugh so
that's an interesting balance when you
when you think about it and one of the
things that we were really excited about
for this game is just the overall theme
of the universe so in garden warfare 2
the zombies have won they won the war in
garden a fair one and they've taken over
so now dr. zomboss and his zombie
minions basically converted you know the
backyard that you know into Zambia you
know that's his vision of the way the
world should be uh and so which kind of
like modes are we see in return because
I'm excited that we had gone ups and now
it's gravy Oh exactly so we've got a
couple of you know by putting the plants
on an attack it's allowed us to do a
couple things so gotten all of you 24
player multiplayer mode that puts the
plants on the attack as well that we
like to call herbalist alt and they're
basically coming back and trying to take
over somber be and then we've got sort
of what we're seeing here and what we've
demoed then this is our poor player
zombie co-op mode that we call graveyard
offs and basically it has the plants and
it's allowed us to invent the whole new
what we like to call the Weed swarm that
was kind of where it started what is
this massive plants that they're always
going to be facing off against and you
know we're kind of out in our yard so
and there's weeds coming through the
cracks and there's weeds coming through
and it just was like that's the perfect
sort of thing zomboss loves metal and
building stuff and the weeds are
constantly growing out and taking it
down and then from there we could start
building all these great big bosses
there's such as so many characters in
the pvz universe and again right here
the idea of the boss slot mechanic you
never know what's going on sometimes
it's great and then it's kind of like
well jackpot but its jackpots means
you're facing off a ton of Giga
Torchwood's oh wow that tree just kind
of bear out of the ground when it comes
to um you got a bunch of new classes
let's talk a little bit about the new
guys we're gonna be playing us because I
think another great thing that you're
doing is stuff you've unlocked in the
original game is coming you'll be able
to access it in garden warfare 2 s.i
great yeah that's right so any character
that you've unlocked in garden warfare
one you're going to be able to then
transfer into garden warfare 2 if you
want to some people just want to unlock
them again that's totally okay me I'll
take my army and move them forward in
addition to that you know we we have the
six brand new classes we're creating
brand new variants for all of the
existing garden warfare one characters
as well so you're going to see crazy
crazy new versions of those characters
that's going to bring the total number
of playable characters and gone or 422
over a hundred down Wow how are you
gonna choose like we leave that up to
you 34 pages so we have new classes as
well we saw on the Xbox stage a very
very set suave looking like tangerine
thing going on yeah it's got about these
guys I mean basically by putting the
zombies on a little bit more defense and
the plants a little more offense it
allowed us to introduce new play styles
into the game and so you go from the IMP
in the Mac where the Imps the smallest
fast guy he's really up to your knee he
can all sort of play with cover but in
and he whips in and whips out doing lots
of stuff but when he gets in trouble and
gets to where he needs he can call down
his tzemach and become the biggest and
strongest character in the game and
stomp on those plans and do all sorts of
great stuff and then we've got other
characters like we introduce captain
dead beard the pirate who's really the
zombies long-range specialist now and so
he's got a feature that we really like
in garden warfare 2 is we're making the
weapons a little bit more adaptive so
not only when you have his weapon
normally and you pull the right trigger
up close we call it the scurvy
scattershot and take stuff out close but
when you pull in that left trigger to
zoom his telescope comes out and it
becomes a long-range sniper rifle and
really gives him a lot of utility on the
field and then he's got his parent pel
that lets him fly around drop in
explosions and then yeah he's got a
couple of other crazy things from his
every pirate has a trustee barrel and he
hops into his barrel when it gets in
trouble ever and I renessa everywhere
that's what we've determined on our team
it's a known fact that every pirate has
a barrel but you're in there you don't
take any damn it or lease damage you're
safe and then you basically pull the
trigger like the fuse and
room into a crowd you go Justin's got a
few other tricks he likes to do with
that barrel oh yes and then we've got
the superhero character and then on the
plant side we've got such on who you
were referring to so he is actually a
bounty hunter orange from the future
because of course is we've also got
kernel corn and he is a corn that was
fighting overseas and when he heard that
the zombies have taken over suburbia
he's come back to lend a hand and he's
going to be more of a run-and-gun
assault class and then we have rose and
Rose is a mystical seer from the past
and she had basically a vision of the
future and it was full of zombies so
she's traveled through time to use her
magical arts and help out the plant team
what kind of medical arts do yeah I mean
so so time travel is a big part of this
as well you know characters coming from
different time periods it's it's part of
pvz universe now and we're really
excited about all those new classes yeah
but Rose is kind of cool I mean she's a
bit mischievious and says she's got a
spell so with a flick of a wrist she's
got that one she can literally turn his
on me into a goat and if you're that
zombie player got turned into a goat
you're gonna be a playable goat running
around the game you can only play a goat
in our game as a zombie ignore warfare
two wonderful guys will be seeing the
game early next year I believe no family
stages yeah I just think I'll thank you
so much for joining me guys make sure
you don't go anywhere for more game
sports coverage head over against wanna
come youtube.com slash III and of course
hitbox TV / gamespot we've got more
awesome demos coming up on the stage
make sure you don't go anywhere